[Music]
oh
hey there
how was my day
intense really
intense
full of so many ups and downs
the ups and downs are because the
pre-frontal cortex of adolescents brains
are not fully mature
it is the area responsible for planning
prioritizing and controlling impulses
good afternoon okay though
hubert intense days at work can produce
health problems
starting with high levels of stress
insomnia
depression
this is my dear friend kato
he's not great at small talk but he
certainly lives up to his name
cato means all knowing
so i take it upon myself to learn as
much as i can
and share some of that wisdom whenever i
get the chance
why don't we head home so that i can
double check your neurochemical
reactions under my microscope
sure okay though
but i have to pick up some groceries
first
i love my time in the core
but the pressure can get a bit
overwhelming sometimes new country new
friends new grocery shops with projects
i don't even recognize there's so many
new things happening around me and
sometimes i forget to care of myself you
know the deal hubert
i keep telling you we need a course on
mental health
she did say it
once
last tuesday at 6 47 pm
exactly it could help so many people
during their time with the corps they
could learn some useful techniques and
we can make them do challenges oh no no
no no no wait let's call them quests
and this is my exuberant futuristic
fashionista friend allegra
which means happiness in latin
oh
oh i know if if cato provides the facts
and science behind mental health i can
talk about being happy
more than one out of every six people in
the eu suffers from mental health
problems
that's almost 84 million people
wow you see i didn't know that
okay okay we definitely need to learn
more about this
sounds like a good start
what else could we talk about
hey what about me
surely you need emotions
feelings hubert you need to shake shake
shake it up and this is shake
spear
oh
emotions
emotions
wherefore are thou
emotions
okay thanks shake
lovely voice you've got there
my friend
it is an honor to provide the emotions
that this course is missing
happiness can be an emotion
feelings and happiness go hand in hand
we will look into our souls reflect
breathing the words of poetry and
musical geniuses
oh dear
we
will break
stereotypes
thank you sheik that could work i still
think something's missing though
you know potato chips contain a chemical
known as acrylamide that could increase
the risk of health complications
chocolate now this is what i call
emotional comfort food
no no no no no no chocolate does not
bring lasting happiness
that's exactly what i mean
we need
balance whoa
did somebody say they needed balance
as a libra i'm all about balance and
harmony oh who bird
yes i can see why you called
i know a thing or two about self-care
it's all about balancing our physical
intellectual
and spiritual dimensions
in a fun way i promise
of course on mental health
this could really work
we'll cover the science of cato
the road to happiness with allegra
how to embrace our emotions with shake
and libra will tie it all together with
the famous trio the physical
the intellectual
and spiritual dimension
i don't know about you
but this is all starting to sound great
we'll have quests testimonials from
former participants techniques to apply
to mental health music
podcasts
books
movie recommendations
reflection moments
all of this will require
time
exactly kato they need time it's not a
sprint people can learn at their own
pace quiz could take an hour or even a
week maybe they want to start a new
habit and then come back later for the
next topic
kato my friend
why don't you get us started
wait
what
me
are you ready
[Music]
you